[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في سابقه من نوعها منذ تسلمه مهامه امينا
عاما للامم المتحده فعل انطونيو جوتيريش
الماده ال9 من ميثاق الامم المتحده وفي
رساله لرئيس مجلس الامن الدولي حذر فيها
بحسب المتحدث باسمه ستيفان دوجريك اعضاء
المجلس من مخاطر الوضع في قطاع غزه على
السلم والامن الدوليين وحثهم على الضغط من
اجل تجنب وقوع كارثه الانسانيه وطلبهم
بالدعوه الى وقف اطلاق نار انساني التحرك
الاممي ايده مفوض الشؤون الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل الذي حث
مجلس الامن على التحرك فورا لمنع انهيار
كامل للوضع المعيشي في قطاع غزه رئيس
الوزراء الاسباني بيدرو سانشيز اكد من
جانبه تاييده الكامل خطبه جوتيريش وقال ان
الكارثه الانسانيه في قطاع غزه لا تطاق
اوروبيا ايضا جددت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
دعوتها
لهدني جديده في غزه تؤدي لاحقا الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار هناك كما دعت الى
احترام القانون الدولي الانساني في غزه
واعتماد مبدا التناسب في استخدام القوه
فقبلته اوروبا بالتاييد ازعج تل ابيب التي
وصفت ولايه جوتيريش بانها تمثل تهديدا
للسلام العالمي واضافت ان تفعيله الماده
ال9 ودعوته لوقف اطلاق النار في غزه
يشكلان دعما لمنظمه حماس الارهابيه وفق
تعبيرها وفي واشنطن التي بدت اقرب الى
الموقف الاسرائيلي من دعوه جوتيريش نقل
نقل بالاحرى عن وزير الخارجيه ابلاغه
اسرائيل قناعه اداره بايدن بان الصراع يجب
ان ينتهي خلال اسابيع لا
اشهر لمناقشه موض مضوع اليوم معنا من
القدس الاكاديميه والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيليه الدكتور محمد هلسه وهنا في
الاستديو الكتور لقاء مكي الباحث الاول في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات ولكن قبل ان نبدا
النقاش نتوقف مع هذه المقابله التي كنا قد
اجريناها قبل قليل مع المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ستيفان دوجريك الذي
سالناه في بدايتها عن توقعاته بشان مصير
تفعيل جوتيريش الماده ال9 من ميثاق الامم
المتحده واز
كما
قلت هذه خطوه غير مسبوقه من قبل السيد
جوتيريس او من اي امين عام لان
يذكر الماده 99
ويطلق صوته ليلفت انتباه مجلس الامن من
التهديد الخطير للامن الدولي وما نتمناه
هو انه يدفع الى
مجلس الامن الى اتخاذ خطوات للدعوه الى
وقف لاطلاق النار وقف انساني لاطلاق النار
و الامارات العربيه المتحده وضعت مشروع
قرار لتتم مناقشته والتصويت عليه من قبل
مجلس الامن يعني هناك جو من التفاؤل
لترجمه هذه
الخطوه التفاؤل هي كلمه لا اعتقد ان
نخدمها كثيرا في سياق الازمه الحاليه في
غزه وفي اسرائيل نامل ان ان ما قام به
الامين العام سوف يدفع عددا من اعضاء مجلس
الامن والمجتمع الدولي ليكون في مستوى
مسؤوليتهم
ويحافظوا ول
يتفادوا كارثه انسانيه
خطره في في غزه واسرائيل حاليا اذا تجنبنا
مفهوم التفاؤل او التشاؤم هل هناك واقعيه
في تجاوب مجلس
الامن لمثل هذه
المبادره
يمكن ما هو موجود هو التصميم من جانب
الامين العام لاستمرار في الدفع وفي
الدعوه الى الى ان نرى وقفا اطلاق النار
لاسباب انسانيه راينا في غزه اكثر من
15000 قتلى واكثر من 40 ال مصابين واكثر
من 1000 شخص في اسرائيل قتلوا ايضا من قبل
هجم هجوم حماس في السابعه من اكتوبر اذا
المعاناه الانسانيه ينبغي ان تتوقف
والقاتل ينبغي ان
يتوقف اذا نظام الانساني على شفا هاويه
وينبغي لكي يستطيع
هنا حا العم والساده الانسان اذا تجاهل
مجلس الامن او احد الاعضاء الدائمين فيه
وسعى لعرقله هذا التوجه هل هناك في
الميثاق ما يفتح مجال اخر للامين
العام السلطه التي لدى مجلس الامن واض
ليس لديه لدى الامين العام صوت نحن
واقعيون كما تحدثت عن وهناك تحديات في
مجلس الامن لكي يحصل على قرار بالاجماع
حول الدعوه الى وقف اطلاق النار سبب
انسانيه
ونامل ان يتم تجاوز ذلك من اجل
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين حتى تسكت
البنادق ويتم القيام بالجهد
اذا ينبغي ان يكون هناك طريقه لتحقيق
ذلك لماذا اسالك هذا السؤال سيد دوجريك
لان نائب المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس
الامن قال وهنا اقتبس بالضبط ماذا قال قال
افضل شيء هو استمرار الدبلوماسيه الهادئه
وراء الكواليس وكانه لا يعبر عن حماسه لما
قام به السيد
جوتيريش
نحن نتفهم ان الاعضاء لديهم وجهات نظر
مختلفه وامور ينبغي ان ياخذوها بعين
الاعتبار ليس علي انا ان اعلق على كل ما
يقوله عضو هذا البلد او ذاك ومره اخرى نحن
واقعيون حول الوضع والامين العام هو مصمم
من اجل الاستمرار في هذه الجهود وعلينا ان
نتذكر ونذكر جميع زملائنا علينا ان
نتذكرهم الذين هم في منطقه قتال ومستمرون
بكل عزيمه واثار على تقديم الدعم ومساعده
الرجال والنساء الذين يحتاجون المساعدات
الانسانيه وهم يفعلون ذلك معرضين انفسهم
لمخاطره كبيره لان هناك اكثر من 100 فرد
من العاملين في المساعدات الانسانيه فقدوا
حياتهم لا تعلق على التصريح الذي قلته
ولكن هل لكم ان تعلقوا على هذا على الاقل
لانه واضح ومباشر حينما يقول وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي بان ولايه جوتيريش
هنا ايضا اقتبس ولايه جوتيريش خطر على
السلام العالمي وما قام به هو دعم لحركه
حماس ودعم لقتل المدنيين واختطاف الاطفال
والاعتداء على
النساء
اعتقد اي
ملاحظ ينظر الى ما قاله الامين العام بشكل
بعقل منفتح يفهم بوضوح ما هو موقفه هو الى
جانب ايقاف القتل وادانه الارهاب وايقاف
المعاناه والى جانب السلام والى جانب
المصالحه والتصالح
دعني الان اعطيه جرعه ايجابيه على الاقل
جوزف بوريل رحب بخطوه الامين العام وكذلك
رئيس الوزراء الاسباني هل تتوقعون المزيد
في هذا
الاتجاه اعتقد اننا نرحب بالدود الفعل
الايجابيه وعلينا ان نراها يتم ترجمتها
الى اعمال ايجابيه متى تتوقعون عمليا ان
يبدا مجلس الامن الدولي في المشاورات
اللازمه
ل
مع مسعى الامين
العام نتوقع الامين العام ان يت يخاطب
مجلس الامن قبل نهايه الاسبوع ستكون تلك
بدايه جيده لكن نتفهم ان هناك مناقشات
دائره الان هذه
الخطوه لكننا لا نتحكم في
اعمالهم لكي نتوقع وقتا معينا ما اقدم
عليه
السيد يعمل به منذ 30 عاما هل معنى ذلك ان
ما يجري الان في غزه خطير الى درجه حتى
تتجاوز ما كان يحصل قبل اشهر والى الان في
في
اوكرانيا اتقد انا لا
اقارن ولكن قد يكون ذلك في احترام لمن
يعانون لكن ما هو واضح من رساله الامين
العام هو انه
يؤكد على مخاطر المرض والاوبئه و وال
النزوح ال بشكل كبير لاعداد هائله من
الناس وسيكون هناك انعكاس اكثر خطوره على
المنطقه وما حولها طبعا ما قام به سيد
جوتيريس هو دفع مجلس الامن للنظر بشكل جدي
في ما يجري في غزه مع احتمال ان تصل
الامور حتى الى البند السابع هل لديكم اي
توقعات ايجابيه في هذا في هذا
الاتجاه مره اخرى انا لست مقامرا واعتقد
انه من الصعب توقع ما يمكن ان يحدث نعرف
ما يدعو اليه الامين العام وان الدول
الاعضاء في مجلس الامن يتعاملون بجديه ما
دعى اليه الان يحتاجون الى اتخاذ قرارات
والى العمل في النهايه سيد د جريك هل ما
قام به الامين العام هو قد يكون الفرصه
الاخيره لانقاذ سمعه ومصداقيه مجلس الامن
في معالجه الازمات
الدوليه لا اريد ان اقوم بهذا النوع من
التوقعات لكن الوضع على الارض سيء ج جدا
وعندما نرى اعداد المدنيين الذين يقتلون
والاطفال
والنساء والناس الذين يختفون وكل هذه
الامور التي تجري نحتاج الى ان
نجد كمجتمع دولي طريقه لايقاف هذه المذبحه
ولاتخاذ وقف لاطلاق النار باسرع ما
يمكن نرحب من جديد بضيفي نبدا بالدكتور
لقاء مكي هنا هل ما اقدم عليه الامين
العام يمكن ان يعطي دفعه جديده للنقاشات
حول غزه في الامم المتحده طبيعي جدا ودفعه
قويه ولذلك هناك انزعاج اسرائيلي شديد كما
راينا وايضا حتى انزعاج
امريكي يعني بالنهايه هذه
الدعوه تنبه مجلس الامن للموضوع وتجبر على
مناقشته هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى هي
تضع العالم امام امام حقيقه اخلاقيه انه
الامين العام يعتبر هذا النزاع للمره
الاولى في تاريخ الامم المتحده مهدد الامن
والسلم الدوليين وهذا اقصى صلاحيه للامين
العام للامم المتحده يستخدمها بالتالي
مجلس الامن سيكون من الناحيه الاخلاقيه
وليس فقط من الناحيه يعني من الناحيه
النظريه يكون مسؤول وملزم بمتابعه هذه
القضيه وتطوراتها وتداعياتها هذا حتى على
المستوى
العملي سيضع اسرائيل امام استحقاقات الزمن
حتى ان كان هناك غطاء امريكي دامه الو وقت
ومنح مزيد من الوقت لكنه سيكون اقصر مما
كان متوقعا سيكون هناك مثل ما قال بلينكن
اسابيع وليس اشهرا ولكن حتى الاسابيع
ستكون اقصر لذلك فتره نهايه العام يعني
بعد حوالي 20 يوم هي فتره قد تكون واقعيه
جدا بالتفكير طبعا دكتور هلس ردود الفعل
الاسرائيليه خاصه على لسان وزير الخارجيه
كانت عنيفه جدا وشخصيه حتى على الامين
العام لماذا كل هذا
انزعاج لان اسرائيل لم تعتد ان ترى في هذه
المنظومه الدوليه وهذه المنابر الدوليه
التي للاسف وضعت للضعفاء من يغرد خارج
سربها ومن يخالف سردتها لذلك هي لا ليست
منزعجه من الاثر الذي قد يترتب عليها في
الجانب العملي هي منزعجه لانها تقيم نفسها
الها في الارض ولا تريد لاحد ان يخرج عن
سردتها وتلاحق الكل من يغرد خارج هذا السر
بالتهديد والوعيد والتقريع وموقف اسرائيل
الذي عبر عنه وزير خارجيتها هو موقف
الرسمي الذي يعني نامل مثل هذه المنابر
بمعنى انه يعني سقف المتوقع منها هو سقف
مجرد يعني
اي يعني اطلاق تصريحات لا يمكن ان تسمن
ولا تغني من جوع هذه المنظمه والمنابر
الدوليه التي لم تقدم لشعبنا المحتل منذ
اكثر من 75 عاما والذي يعني ترتكب اسرائيل
بحق المجازر والتي هي ل للاسف يعني هنالك
قرارات صدرت يعني عن مجلس الامن بحق ال
اسرائيل ولم تنفذ منذ سنوات وهي موضوع على
الرف لماذا الان ستنفذ اسرائيل هذه
القرارات وهي تحضى بهذا الغطاء الامريكي
اسرائيل بالنسبه لها ما دامت الولايات
المتحده معها اذا كل الصدى الذي يحدث
العالمي هذا لا يؤثر في سلوكها وبالتالي
هي ستستمر لن ترى في هذه التصريحات سوى
مزيد من الاصوات التي تملا الفضاء والتي
تاتي في سياق الحاله العامه الدوليه
المنقلبه على على على هذا هذا هذه الاباده
لم ي الموقف الامريكي طبعا الموقف
الامريكي مثل ما اشرت هنا اسال الكتور
لقاء مكي الموقف الامريكي بدا فاترا في
التجاوب مع
الامر هل هل تعتقد عرقله لهذا التوجه
عندما يتحدث مثل ما قال دوجريك عندما
يتحدث الامين العام في مجلس الامن ربما
قبل نهايه الاسبوع هو هناك جلسه هي جلسه
مسبقا كانت مقره قبل هذا التصريح وبالتالي
سيكون هناك احراج بالتاكيد الاداره
الامريكيه ليست فقط يعني هادئه بالتعامل
ولكن هي محرجه بالحقيقه ولا تحاول ان تذهب
الى راي او موقف من ال من طلب الامين
العام كي لا تكون يعني الطرف المضاد
للميثاق ميثاق الدولي او او للامين العام
او للقانون الدولي هي اعتقد ستحاول ان
تجعل مجلس الامن يبطئ عمليه اتخاذ قرار
يعني تحاول حتى ان لا تصل الى مرحله
القرار او التصويت
كي لا تحرج في استخدام الفيتو في قضيه
تهدد الامن والسلم الدوليين هذا امر يعني
متوقع فيما يتعلق بمثل هذا التصرف او مثل
هذا الموقف اللي وضعت فييه الدكتور هل
الموقف الاوروبي على العكس بدا متجاوبا
ومتفهما لمسعى جوتيريش هل هي بدايه تعميق
الانفكاك بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده في
النظر الى ما يجري في غزه على الاقل من
وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه يعني
ابدا الموقف الاوروبي ضعيف وخجول ومنافق
تاريخيا ظل هذا سقفه مع اسرائيل في
التعامل مع اسرائيل وانت رايت المتحدث
كلما سالته سؤالا ظل يحافظ على مساحه من
الدبلوماسيه ولا يريد يعني ان يصب جام غضب
الاسرائيلي عليه في تصريح قد يفهم بهذه
الصوره او تلك انه متعاطف مع الفلسطينيين
حتى في اطار الحديث عن المعاناه تحدث ساوى
بين القاتل والمقتول ساوى
بين الاحتلال وادواته واجرامه وبين ال
الشعب الفلسطيني واطفاله الذين يبادون اذا
نحن نفهم الموقف الاوروبي في اطار
الاحتجاجات التي تجري هذه الحكومات
الاوروبيه بدت منزعجه من او متاثره او
قلقه من حجم الاحتجاجات التي تجري في
شعوبها ومؤسساتها المختلفه والتي تضغط
عليها للاتخاذ مووقف هذه المواقف تاتي فقط
للتجميل لانها تدرك في نهايه المطاف ان
ليس لها اثر قد يردع اسرائيل طالما
الولايات المتحده تقول لا لاسرائيل وحتى
الولايات المتحده في بعض المواقف التي
تظهر منها وكانها يعني تعاتب اسرائيل
وكانها لا تريد لاسرائيل او ت تلوم
اسرائيل هذه ايضا تاتي في اطار ذر الرماد
في العيون ومساحيق تحاول ان تجمل صورتها
امام الهيئات الدوليه لانها لطالما تشدق
بحقوق الانسان وبالدفاع عن حقوق الانسان
وهذا هو الموقف المتوقع لا اكثر يعني ولكن
هناك اشارات دكتور لقاء مكي مثلا من
الخارجيه الفرنسيه بدات تقترب اكثر فاكثر
من مواقف مختلفه عن عن الامريكيين هل يمكن
لدينا فرنسا ولدينا بريطانيا في في مجلس
الامن كاعضاء دائمين هل يمكن ان يختلفوا
بشكل او باخر مع واشنطن هذه المره فرنسا
ممكن بريطانيا صعب صعب طبعا بريطانيا يعني
تتماهى مع امريكا في كل شيء اكثر تحمسا
بالمناسبه لكن فرنسا ممكن اعتقد انه شوف
اولا الغرب يدعم اسرائيل بالمطلق وانتهي
الموضوع هذه من الثوابت المتغير اللي حصل
في هذه الحرب ان الدعم الغربي
المطلق لاسرائيل بدا يهتز رؤيه الغرب
لاسرائيل تهتز ولذلك الموقف الاوروبي
بالعكس اذا كان هناك اي كلام يعتبر
اسرائيل سبب لانتهاك القانون هذا بحد ذاته
تطور ايجابي خطير ومهم لن نجد احد في
الغرب ممكن يدعم حماس على الاقل علنا لن
نجد ابدا وكل اللي راح يصير هو دعم فقط
المساعدات الانسانيه ومنع وقف اطلاق نار
انساني هذا هذا ما يطالب به انساني فقط
لانه باعتبار ان هناك طرف ميليشيا تقاتل
اسرائيل و وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذا بحد ذاته
يعتبر مكسب هو المهم وقف اطلاق النار
وحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني هذا هو اهم شيء
اما المساواه بين القات الضحيه فهذا نمط
دولي معروف منذ تاسيس اسرائيل ولا يمكن ان
نتوقع شيء اخر في هذه الحاله على الاقل او
المرحله لكن مجرد التغيير هو بحد ذاته
تطور مهم ربما لو لو تعود الهدى قد تخفف
من من من الحرج يصبح وقف اطلاق النار
الانساني ضمن الهدنه ربما اي هدنه جديده
ستحصل ستقود الى وقف اطلاق النار شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور لقاء مكي شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور محمد هلسه بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نصل
الى نهايه حلقه اليوم موعدنا يتجدد باذن
الله غدا في نفس التوقيت الثامنه والنصف
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه طبعا تغطيتنا ما زالت
مستمره لما يجري في غزه بكل تفاصيله المي
المختلفه وتتابع في هذه المستجدات سلمى
الجمل